فدى موقع ريبار العسكريه الروسي ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تتركز بكثافه في الجزء الشمالي
من روبوتينو بمقاطعه ذابولوجيا في اشاره
الى استمرار المعارك وشدد الموقع على ان
القوه الروسيه تضرب مراكز الاحتياطات
الاوكرانيه في مناطق الاحرش في المقابل
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان طائره
حربيه دمرت زورقي استطلاع تابعين للجيش
الاوكراني احدهما امريكي صنع اعلنته
مجموعه انزال شرقي جزيره الافعى والاخر
اقترب من منصات انتاج الغاز الروسي في
البحر الاسود حول هذه التطورات الميدانيه
معنى الانمي موسكو مراسله الجزيره رانيا
دريدي وايضا معنى كمراسل الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم ارحب بكم وابدا معك مازن ابراهيم
الذي يمكن ان يضاف حول التطورات الميدانيه
نعم في الواقع ازدهار يمكن الحديث عن
تقاطع للروايتين الروسيه والاوكرانيه حول
ما يدور فيزا بروجيا عمليا الطرفان يؤكدان
بان معارك تدور داخل روبوتينو وهذا الامر
بمعزل عن من يقول بانه يملك زمام المبادره
في تلك المنطقه يؤكد بان هذه المواجهات
التي اصبحت في داخل المدينه تعني عمليا
بان القوات الاوكرانيه تمكنت من تجاوز خط
الدفاع المتمثل بحقول الالغام في محيط هذه
المدينه في زابولوجيا وتجاوزت ايضا شبكه
الانفاق التي اقامتها القوات الروسيه وبات
القتال في داخل المدينه القوات الروسيه
تقول بان القوات الاوكرانيه تتمركز شمالا
وايضا نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه هي
اشارت الى ان هذه المدينه ما زالت تشهد
حتى هذه اللحظه مواجهات ومعارك عنيفه
وبالتالي لم يؤكد اي من الطرفين انه سي او
يسيطر على هذه المدينه ولكن الاهميه تكمن
اين بان هذه المنطقه هذا المحور فيزا
بروجيا التي تسيطر على سبعين بالمئه من
اراضيها القوات الروسيه كانت القوات
الاوكرانيه تنفذ ضمن هجومها المضاد الكبير
هجومين ضمن محورين المحور الاول هنا في
شرق البلاد وتحديدا في دونيتس والهجوم
الثاني في زبولوجيا بالنسبه كان هنالك
تعويل على هذا الهجوم كي يخرق الدفاعات
ويتوجه من هذه المدينه من روبوتين وتحديدا
الى عمق المقاطعه بمعنى انه يصل الى
ميليتوبل من جهه والى بريدياسك من جهه
ثانيه في محاوله من القوات الاوكرانيه ان
تربق القوات الروسيه وتقطع هذا الخط الذي
فتحته منذ بدايه الحرب قبل عام ونصف عندما
احتلت 70% من اراضي زابولوجيا وبالتالي
اصبح هنالك ما يوصف المفتوح من الاراضي
الروسيه مرورا الى زياده الكرم لذلك
التكتيك الاوكراني وان كان في بدايه
الهجوم المضاد ينقسم الى مستويين الاول
يتعلق بشرق البلاد في باخموت ومارينكا
وافديافكا وغيرها من المناطق والمستوى
الثاني يرتبط بجنوب البلاد كان هنالك خلال
اليومين الماضيين تصريحات وايضا مصادر
غربيه تحدثت الى مجموعه من الوسائل
الاعلام الغربيه التي اشارت بان واشنطن
كانت تطلب من القياده الاوكرانيه ان تبدا
بتكثيف هجماتها من خلال ضغط كل امكاناتها
ضمن هذه الجبهه تحديدا الجنوبيه لانها قد
تؤدي الى ارباك كبير على مستوى القوات
الروسيا وهو ما دفع بالفعل القوات
الاوكرانيا الى ادخال الفرقه 47 وايضا
الفرقه فرقه اضافيه لمحاوله خلق الدفاعات
في هذا المحور ابقى معنا مازن الان اليك
رانيا وابرز التطورات المدنيه
لو تحدثنا عن التطورات على الارض التطورات
الميدانيه ازدهار يعني يعني دعيني اتحدث
عن اخر معطيات كانت قد صدرت عن وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه التي تحدثت عن القضاء على
اكثر من 700 عسكري اوكراني وذلك في مختلف
المحاور خلال العمليات العسكريه التي
نفذتها القوات المسلحه الروسيه هو رقم
هائل في واقع الامر ازدهار وهذا وهذه
الارقام يمكن القول انها تتكرر يوميا على
الاقل وفقا للروايه الروسيه فيما يتعلق
بتطورات الاوضاع في محور زاكولوجيا نعم
هناك تاكيد من قبل المصادر عسكريه روسيه
على وجود يعني على تواجد عسكري مكثف من
قبل القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه لاسيما في
المناطق الشماليه من منطقه رابوت ولكن من
جهه اخرى تؤكد هذه المصادر ان المعارك
داميه العامه المعارك مستمره وهناك خصم
للقوات المسلحه الروسيه على هذه المواقع
والاهم من ذلك ازدهار ما يلفت الانتباه هو
ما تم الاعلان عنه عن ان القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه على وجه التحديد في هذه
المنطقه قامت بثلاث عمليات اجلاء لقواتها
من هذه المنطقه وذلك خلال الساعات القليله
الماضيه ما ينم ازدهار عن وجود خسائر في
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وحده المعارك
في هذه المنطقه ايضا كانت هناك تصريحات
متعلقه بتطورات الاوضاع في محور في
المناطق الغربيه من باخوت او على مشارف
هذه المدينه القوات المسلحه الروسيه بحسب
التصريحات الصادره سمحت للقوات الاوكرانيه
بالاقتراب من منطقه معينه لاسيمه لوحده
المشاه التابعه للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي قامت بتدميرها وحتى القضاء على
من فر حسب تعبيرها من هذه المنطقه بشكل
نعم ازدهار شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من موسكو
رانيا الدريدي ومن ستيفانسك مازن ابراهيم
شكرا لكم